ciao readers benvenuti in un nuovissimo
b
finite le vacanze sono andata qualche
giorno a torino a casa mia a trovare la
mia mamma
e spulciando po in giro ho trovato una
cosa molto carina che non vi avevo
ancora fatto vedere visto che i video
dei miei diari in cui sfogliavo e
commentavo i miei vecchi diari
scolastici vero piaciuto tantissimo ho
pensato che anche questa volta vi
sareste divertiti a sentire che cosa ci
scrivevamo io e le mie amiche è il block
notes che utilizzavo in terza media per
le dediche dei miei compagni visto che
vedi ai erano bull erano esauriti perché
ogni pagina era piena in terza media
avuto la brillante idea di prendere un
block notes e fare insomma le dediche a
parte quindi vuoi farmi la verità
partiamo ciao mari come va io bene anche
se che palle è tornata alla
professoressa di matematica la più
temuta
che palle la altra prof niente lei era
la lamentosa le spaccherei la faccia
anche un po violenti e tu ora ti faccio
una dedica quindi si è sfogata un po
adesso passiamo alle cose serie
pronti sole d'oro una d'argento la
nostra amicizia al cento per cento e con
classico non si è voluta sprecare ha
usato un copia incolla e co ceo mari
come va
non vedo l'ora che sia domani sono
sicura che ci divertiremo mondo sai mi
piace troppo tu sai chi puntini lei era
furba reach e col cavolo che io scrivo
in nome di quello che mi piace perché
questo block notes potrebbe finire in
mano di chiunque molto molto
intelligente quindi punti vi sono state
di bene se no quindi sicuramente questa
questo ragazzo xt noterà cioè note rame
se tu ti farai notare liscio come l'olio
ciao firmato questa è la mia migliore
amica che saluto poi questo mi sa che un
maschio della scrittura
sì perché ovviamente non è che facciano
solo i nomi che io lo passo
savo questo blog notes se vuoi rischi
che qualcosa bello brutto che fosse uno
dovevi scrivere poi io visionavo al
massimo toglievo buttavo e bruciato nel
camino le como tu stai
ciao vai firmato questa era una dedica
di un maschio a questo in piemontese
addirittura mista propri né simpa né
cioè non mi sta proprio per niente
simpatica muoio non pensa male subito si
arriva nel lazio così da una regione
all'altra
ps mi stai ab simpa tra parentesi
ab bisognava sottolinearlo è la serata
altro maschio che scrive però un po
meglio quindi è più leggibile
sara ciao come si sta laggiù che tempo
fa beh certo perché dalla prima fila
all'ultima c'erano anche dei cambi
metereologici poteva esserci più sole
più dandy topi pioggia normale
bando alle ciance comunque vari nome di
ragazza per me solo simpatica come altro
nome di ragazza e soprattutto come altro
mini ragazza quindi si stava
giustificando perché gli elementi io ero
convinta che vi piacesse questa ragazza
e lui ci guarda me lei sta simpatica
questa simpatico tizio caio e sempronio
la giustificazione non so voi scommetto
che stai ascoltando le tatu all atc
momento musicale tratto all the things e
c'era anche ragazzi senza leggere il
titolo io sapevo già di che canzone
stessimo parlando questa dalla scrittura
riconosco era una delle mie migliori
amiche
ciao mari che confusione sarà perché ti
amo
che confusione adesso io sembro la
cattiva non posso farci niente puntini
nome di ragazza ed io siamo molto amiche
e lei continua a dirmi ho sognato nome
di ragazzo sto pensando ha sempre lo
stesso nome di ragazzo io come faccio
adesso mi ricordo questo ragazzo qua ora
fidanzato comunque aveva baciato questa
mia amica e lei aveva un'altra amica che
era innamorata di lui e quindi non
sapeva come comportarsi quando lei
insomma gli parlava di lui non sarebbe
giusto neanche nei confronti di altro
ragazzo ha quindi questa era contesa
passerà sarà contesa da più ragazzi può
sembrare che non me ne importi nulla ma
non è così probabilmente si sentirà
preso in giro ma io non ne posso niente
lui comunque sapeva già che se fosse
venuto mi fosse avuto ancora dietro
l'avremo la mente già sfruttate mi sono
persa quindi come fare nome di ragazzo
mi odierà dal profondo del suo cuore non
avrà tordo sento che non saremo mai più
amici come lo bravo come lo eravamo
prima di questa storia va beh basta
probabilmente mi interroga vabbè andiamo
avanti compagna di classe semina ciao
mari lo sai che l'anno scorso non mi
stavi molto simpa ma adesso ho capito
che sei davvero simpa non so proprio
cosa scriverti
meno male che la prof non mi ha
interrogato ufi quando non farai più
parte di me ritaglierò dal tuo ricordo
una stella luminosissima in modo che il
giorno si innamori
nella notte
[Musica]
andiamo avanti
ciao mari come va che pizza tecnica
immagino fosse educazione tecnica
a me dispiace tantissimo di non essere
andata in città oggi e a te aquino
eravamo rimasti in classica non a parole
almeno ci perdevamo un giorno di scuola
ovviamente sai che mi stai troppo simpa
ma te l'ho già scritto nella dedica di
prima è quella di prima porta allora
prima l'hanno privano le simpana adesso
un po di più qui rimosso con la lirica
prima mi stai simpatico c'è quindi qui
era già convinto quando un pittore sordo
riuscirà a disegnare il rumore di un
petalo che cade su un tappeto di
cristallo l'hanno definita be there is
anno io ti dimenticherò ciao mare come
va che pizza perché non siamo andati in
gita a questo era un giorno sfigato per
coloro che non rimasti in classe e gli
altri andati in gita
adesso di schivo una dedica sei carina
sei ok resta sempre come sei che carina
ciao mari come stai spero bene sai sono
molto contenta di averti conosciuto
perché sei troppo simpa vabbè ma
arriviamo al dunque mai prendere
decisioni affrettate tranne quando si
sta per precipitare da 3000 m questa la
dedica è il paracadute non si apre
non vedo l'ora che sia sabato peccato
che non vengano i maschi e poi ti devo
dire una cosa a proposito di questo
percepisco una festa solo ragazzo che
però erano graditi anche i maschi ma non
venivano domani oggi vado a vedere se
trovo le basi del canta tu così tra un
po ce le scambiamo che cos'era cantato
era insomma un gioco che vendevano tipo
karaoke dove fu inserirvi il disco
dentro dove c'erano incise delle basi
delle canzoni insomma di quel periodo lì
e il microfono collegato quindi perché
mente era un karaoke e sono collegate
alla tv c'erano anche le parole io ero
completamente patita di questo gioco ci
eravamo presi la mia vita io non sono
molto esperta con le dediche ma ci tengo
a dirti che da quando mi hanno
trasferito qui ho potuto constatare che
sei molto simpatica e se devo essere
sincera non me ne ero mai accorto
ciao mare come tu sai io non sono molto
brava a scriverlo ed è lì che comunque
adesso ti scrivo una dedica io scavo
tuska degli scavano e scaviamo poi
scavate si scavano come dedica non è un
granché però al profonda spero che i
vostri compagni siano più ironici hiraga
sono come motorini più sono belli e più
te li fregano hiraga sono come cessi
pubblici sono sempre occupati hiraga
sono come la pasta più sono cotti e più
sono pc cosi hiraga sono come i pop corn
se ti toccano
prima ti toccano le pop e poi ti fanno
le corna se viene un uomo con la barba
bianca vestita di rosso e bianco e ti
mette in un sacco nero non preoccuparti
vuol dire che hanno chiesto cazzate per
natale sarebbero piange come lo sai che
mi disp
che tu non venga al nome di liceo
c'è simo che mi guarda con uno sguardo
perplesso come se fosse caduto da un
grattacielo tipico lo sguardo che è
caduto da un grattacieli guarda
perplesso
sveglia alle ore 6 30 lavaggio facce
crema doccia più capelli più l'opzione
asciugamento naturale crema corpo
vestiti colazione trucco go un premio un
premio cioè per la dedizione che da anni
o per quanto riguarda la beauty routine
e qua c'è una dedica di san valentino
che non so a chi l'avevo fatta musichina
romantiche il sottofondo
ciao cucciolotto mio
ecco tanti auguri di buon san valentino
spero che il mio regalo ti piaccia anche
se sono praticamente sì ne sono
praticamente sicura sappi che imparare a
volerti bene bellissimo grazie mille
il regalo che sono certa mi piacerà
quindi io non ho ancora ricevuto ho mai
ricevuto io gli avevo già fatto
no vabbè muoia questa è la lista delle
cose che avevo prestato le mie amiche
con il nome dell'amica e sotto le cose
pressate ragazzi cioè imparate a farlo
anche voi perché di vestiti o per sempre
stando alle mie amiche non ve ne sono
anche a dire e concludiamo con questa
lista di canzoni che non so per quale
motivo avevo insomma ha puntato facciamo
un momento carote from sera with love
questa avevo conosciuta a saranno famosi
cioè amici un tempo si chiamava saranno
famosi che facevano sempre nei balletti
e fece fronte
[Musica]
mi piaceva un sacco poi laura non c'è di
nek laura non c'è andata via
ci sei tu di nek quindi next ci piaceva
ci sei tu e io mi illumino di agility se
io non avessi te sempre di nek quindi nè
che era mio idolo
se io non avessi te che alternative
avrei più bella cosa non c'è più bella
cosa dite
e stato divertente rispolverare questi
ricordi insieme a voi spero che insomma
vi siete divertiti anche voi io vi mando
un bacione fatemi sapere se vi piacciono
queste tipologie di video che magari
spulcio a casa se trovo qualcosa altro
interessante e niente ci vediamo al
prossimo video
[Musica]